j'imagine que maman donnait on va se
réveiller et on va se trouver dans un
monde qui peut-être et pas le monde
qu'on aurait aimé créer dès le début
alors dans ce contexte là une question
que je pense est super importante c'est
de demander à tout le monde quel est le
monde que vous voulez créer
[Musique]
faut dire que j'étais un peu déçu de ce
qui est arrivé parce que je pense que on
avait un problème global et on a offert
des solutions on a une réponse qui était
plutôt nationale ce qu'on a vu c'est que
il y a eu des développements qui ont
bénéficié ceux qui se trouvent dans le
Nord et ceux qui ont déjà accès à la
science ceux qui ont accès à des fonds
et ceux qui priorités qui ont eu comme
priorité comme j'ai dit leur propre
intérêts
je pense que oui il y a un grand risque
qu'on va voir que c'est les intérêts
d'une certaine segment de la population
qui vont avoir
accès à certains bénéfices tandis que
d'autres vont se trouver toujours dans
une situation où ils vont subir les
conséquences sans avoir eu accès aux
bénéfices et alors dans ce contexte là
je pense qu'on devrait vraiment prendre
en ligne de compte ou se fait la
recherche qui a accès au fond où se fait
la gouvernance et quel en sont les
priorités
ce que je vois c'est que vraiment on n'a
pas pris en ligne de compte les
priorités de différentes personnes alors
vraiment c'est les priorités qui ont été
développées grosso modo dans le Nord qui
dirige la science alors peut-être si on
demande à certaines communautés dans le
sud peut-être il voudrait poser
différentes questions avoir différentes
priorités par exemple qui va contrôler
cette science qui va être en mesure
d'avoir accès à ces données est-ce que
la police va avoir accès à ce que le
gouvernement va avoir accès est-ce que
le médecin va avoir accès est-ce que
c'est l'individu qui va contrôler qui va
avoir accès ça c'est des questions très
précis et à savoir qui va avoir la
possibilité de répondre à ces questions
et effectivement de faire en sorte que
la gouvernance est bien alignée avec ses
réponses
[Musique]
faut absolument comprendre le temps pour
poser et répondre à ces questions un des
grands problèmes qu'on a présentement
c'est qu'on vit dans un monde où on sait
organiser de façon qu'on ne fait
attention que des questions à court
terme et ceci est en conséquence de la
situation politique si on est policier
on veut être élu donc on travaille pour
deux ans peut-être et par la suite on
prend les prochaines deux années pour
faire en sorte qu'on va être réélu mais
nous maintenant on a des problèmes de
grande envergure alors ça prend une
réponse qui va peut-être durer 10 années
25 années 50 années il faut planifier
pour ça
[Musique]